a good set of results for us and builds
on the success that we saw on local
election night mr lammy my apologies we
have to go to the president of the
united states
a very solemn moment
today the supreme court of the united
states
expressly took away
a consciousness right from the america
that had already recognized
they didn't limit it
they simply took it away
that's never been done to a right so
important to so many americans
but they did it
it's a sad day for the court and for the
country
50 years ago roe v wade
was decided and has been the law of the
land since then this landmark case
protected woman's right to choose
her right to make intensely personal
decisions with her doctor
free from entertainment from the
interference of politics
it reaffirmed basic principles of
equality
that women have the power to control
their own destiny
and it reinforced a fundamental right of
privacy
the right of each of us to choose how to
live our lives
now with rogue on
let's be very clear
the health and life of women in this
nation
are now at risk
as chairman and ranking member of the
senate judiciary committee
as vice president now as president
united states
i've studied this case carefully
i've overseen more supreme court
confirmations than anyone today
where this case was always discussed
i believe roe v wade was the correct
decision
as a matter of constitutional law and
application of the fundamental right
to privacy and liberty and matters of
family and personal autonomy
it was a decision on a complex matter
that drew a careful balance between a
woman's right to choose
earlier in her pregnancy and the state's
ability to regulate
later in her pregnancy
a decision with broad national consensus
that most americans of faith
and backgrounds found acceptable
that have been the law of the land for
most of the lifetime
of americans today
and it was a constitutional principle
upheld
by justices appointed by democrat
and republican presidents alike
roe v wade was a 7-2 decision
written by a justice appointed by a
republican president richard nixon
in the five decades that followed roe v
wade justice is appointed by republican
presidents from eisenhower
nixon and reagan
george w bush
were among the justices who voted to
uphold the principles set forth in roe v
wade
it was three justices named by one
president
donald trump
were the core of today's decision to
upend the scales of justice and
eliminate a fundamental right for women
in this country
make no mistake
this decision is a culmination of a
deliberate effort over decades
to upset the balance of our law
it's a realization of an extreme
ideology and a tragic error by the
supreme court in my view
the court has done what it has never
done before
expressly take away a constitutional
right
that is so fundamental
to so many americans that had already
been recognized
the court's decision to do so will have
real and immediate consequences
state laws banning abortion
are automatically taking effect today
jeopardizing the health of millions of
women
some without exceptions
so extreme that women could be punished
for protecting her health
so extreme the women and girls were
forced to bear their rapist
child
for the child a consequence
it just it just stuns me
so extreme the doctors will be
criminalized for fulfilling their duty
to care
imagine having a young woman having to
carry a child
of incest as a consequence of incest
no option
too often the case
the poor women are going to be hit the
hardest it's cruel
in fact the court laid out
state laws criminalizing abortion
that go back to the 1800s
as rationale
the court literally
taking america back 150 years
this is a sad day for the country in my
view
but it doesn't mean the fight's over
let me be very clear and unambiguous
the only way we can secure a woman's
right to choose
the balance that existed
is for congress to restore the
protections of roe v wade as federal law
no executive action from the president
can do that
and if congress
as it appears
lacks the vote to vote to do that now
voters need to make their voices heard
this fall
we must elect more senators
representatives who will codify
the woman's right to choose in the
federal law once again
elect more state leaders to protect this
right at the local level
we need to restore the protections of
roe
as law of the land we need to elect
officials who will do that
this fall roe is on the ballot
personal freedoms are on the ballot
the right to privacy
liberty equality
they're all on the ballot
until then
i will do all of my power to protect a
woman's right in states
where they will face the consequences of
today's decision
while the court's decision casts a dark
shadow over a large swath of the land
many states in this country still
recognize the woman's right to choose
so
if a woman lives in a state that
restricts abortion
the supreme court's decision does not
prevent her from traveling from her home
state to the state that allows it
it does not prevent a doctor
in that state
and that state from treating her
as the attorney general has made clear
women must remain free to travel safely
to another state to seek care they need
my administration will defend that
bedrock right
if any state or local official high or
low
tries to interfere with a woman's
exercise and her basic right to travel i
will do everything in my power
to fight that deeply un-american attack
my administration will also protect the
woman's access to medications
that are approved by the food and drug
administration the fda
like contraception
which is essential for preventative
health care
nifoprestone
which the fda approved 20 years ago
to safely end early pregnancies
and is commonly used to treat
miscarriages
some states are saying that they'll try
to ban or severely restrict access to
these medications
but extremist governors and state
legislators are looking to block the
mail
or search the person's medicine cabinet
or control a woman's actions by tracking
data on her apps she uses are wrong and
extreme and out of touch
with the majority of americans
the american medical association
the american college of obstetricians
and gynecologists
wrote to me and vice president harris
stressing that these laws are not based
on are not based on evidence and asking
us to act to protect access to care they
say by limiting access to these
medicines
maternal mortality will climb in america
that's what they say
today i'm directing the department of
health and human services
to take steps
to ensure these critical medications are
available
to the fullest extent possible
and the politicians cannot interfere
in the decisions that should be made
between a woman and her doctor
and my administration will remain
vigilant
as the implications of this decision
play out
i've warned about how this decision
risked the broader right to privacy for
everyone
that's because roe recognized the
fundamental right to privacy
that has served as a basis for so many
more rights that have come to take we've
come to take for granted
that are ingrained in the fabric of this
country
the right to make the best decisions for
your health
the right to use birth control a married
couple in the privacy of their bedroom
for god's sake
the right to marry the person you love
justice thomas said as much today he
explicitly called
to reconsider the right of marriage
equality
the right of couples to make their
choices on contraception
this extreme and dangerous path the
court is now taking us on
let me close the two points
first
i call on everyone no matter how deeply
they care about this decision
to keep all protests peaceful
peaceful peaceful peaceful no
intimidation
violence is never acceptable
threats
and tim and intimidation are not speech
we must stand against violence in any
form
regardless of your rationale
second
i know
so many of us are frustrated and
disillusioned the court has taken
something away that's so fundamental
i know so many women are now going to
face incredibly difficult situations
i hear you
i support you
i stand with you the consequences
and the consensus
of the american people
core principles of equality
liberty
dignity and the stability of the rule of
law
demand that roe should not have been
overturned
with this decision
the conservative majority of the supreme
court shows how extreme it is
how far removed they are from the
majority of this country
they've made the united states an
outlier among developed nations in the
world
but this decision
must not be the final word
my administration will use all of its
appropriate lawful powers
but congress must act
and with your vote
you can act
you can have the final word
this is not over
thank you very much more to say this in
weeks to come thank you
[Music]
that was president uh biden there of
course uh addressing that uh historic
decision by the uh supreme court to
overturn their prior decision from 1973
uh that gave abortion rights across the
country and overturned roe v wade he
said it was a sad day for the quarter
sad day for the country he said i
believe roe v wade was the correct
decision back in 1973 thanks to the
fundamental right to privacy he also
mentioned the fact that he felt there
was a broad national consensus even
consensus for it to remain even
from those of faith explained how roe v
wade originally was a 7-2 decision
written by a justice who had been
appointed by a republican and president
nixon
he said though that this doesn't mean
the fight is over he said the only way
we can enshrine rights across the
country is a new federal law from
congress and voters need to make their
voices heard he said this fall
referencing of course the midterm
elections to come in november that roe v
wade was on the ballot and he said as is
so often the case
this will fall on poor women the hardest
let's discuss all of this further
joining me now from newton massachusetts
is uh judy norsigen a co-founder of the
pro-choice group our bodies
ourselves um
thanks so much for joining me judy this
evening on this decision
i mean we heard there from from the
president uh saying the only way to